this episode of star talk is brought to
you by curiosity stream hello youtuber
verse Neil deGrasse Tyson here your
personal astrophysicist coming up cosmic
queries edition of star talk all about
comets and asteroids this is Startalk
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and today is a
cosmic queries edition of star talk and
I've got with me
co-host mark Normand mark nice the first
timer hey big fan happy to be here thank
you your local New Yorker local got lost
in the museum like an idiot if you have
to get lost anywhere let it be the
American Museum of Natural History
that's true the day yes that would be
terrifying you don't want to get lost at
night no I sadly I was using my night at
the Museum knowledge oh I've seen the
movie you using your your coordinate
system from that movie yeah avoid nobody
you got here in one piece which is
excellent today's topic is comets and
asteroids and I know a little something
about it but I don't know as much as I
should know about it to carry this
episode alone so we went in for backup
nice and there's a good friend of ours
who's been a guest before Natalie
Starkey Natalie welcome back to Startalk
hi Neil hi Mark it's great to be here
thanks for having me we've got you
online you are in a lipstick oh so
you're in the UK right now is that
correct yes yes I am I was over in
California for about three years living
over there and now I'm back in the UK
getting used to the rain again and the
cold and I'm very miserable and he got
spoiled that you were so accessible to
us over those three years forget
anything that you're basically a UK
person so so there is yeah you're you're
officially a science communicator that's
like a title that you carry for the Open
University just outside of London right
yes that's correct yes so I've been a
scientific researcher for about 10 or 11
years and I got into writing and I love
communicating this
I do see I'm getting into it more
seriously now so I've sort of like I've
got a serious science background I know
quite a bit about comets and asteroids
so hopefully I can be of yeasterday I'm
hoping fingers crossed
so we've got and I happen to have I
think what is your latest book called
catching Stardust yeah comets asteroids
and the birth of the solar system I have
it in my lap I had to do a bit of
product placement
you know exactly exactly but you had to
come back one day and sign it definitely
so we called questions from our fan base
yes on this topic of comets and
asteroids and so let's let's see what
you got neither she nor I have seen
these questions all right let's check
them out okay kind of nerve-wracking I'm
a bit I'm a bit worried I hate having my
knowledge tested you know just say I
have no freaking idea go onto the next
question right okay all right these are
pretty good I've read a few and I'm
gonna go hand pick first one should I
give the whole name and everything get
away from ya all right this first one's
from Kyle Ryan Toth he's a patreon
member patreon we got to serve them
first yeah exactly would it really be
possible to hollow out an asteroid and
use it as a starship okay so I'm gonna
say no straight off just to be really
boring but actually one of the reasons
we couldn't really do this well with
most asteroids anyway is that they're
either just too hard or they're just not
made of the right stuff so you know
we've got some asteroids that are made
completely of metal so I mean trying to
hold that out would be almost impossible
you know we've talked about you know
mining these in the past and we talked
about them to show you quite a bit and
and it's incredibly difficult to do that
so I think mining a pure metal asteroid
would be hard and then the others that
are made of you know there could be a
slightly softer we described some of
them as a bit of a rubble pile so they
kind of just Rock
that's not very well consolidated not
very well pushed together so that would
basically break up as soon as you try to
stop excavating it in any way so you'd
have a better chance maybe living on the
surface but I think even then you know
there's no gravity essentially so
they're kind of hard beasts to work with
don't think we're gonna live inside one
so the very low gram they have some
gravity right they do they do have a
little bit and basically you would need
to be tethered onto the surface of one
it if maybe we went to the largest
asteroid in the asteroid belt which is
Sarah's it's about a thousand kilometers
across so it's gonna have a little bit
of gravity but if you jumped too high
and you you would probably just end up
floating off into space so it's not
gonna be a great environment to try and
live on or in rather yeah so I think
that the lesson there is just make your
own damn spaceship yeah but could you
get a rudder on there I mean could you
steer you know what I mean I feel like
you wouldn't get any any directionality
Oh I mean if it's just a hollowed out
yeah yeah you need some kind of
retrorockets affixed to the side of it
so that you can maneuver exactly rather
than just like a homeless shelter inside
a shell yeah they were thinking of with
that question yeah yeah I mean it's a
fun thought all right let me throw it
this guy
he's ready go for it Kyle you blew it
nice job he's smoking weed one picture
on all right this from Michael Halterman
can comets have different colors
diversity may be when the ingredients in
organic molecules are different can they
spread molecules for the beginning of
life yeah okay so there's sort of two
questions there so the first bit was
about the colors of them and yeah for
sure when we see comets in the night sky
they they can glow different colors and
actually Green is a really common color
in what when we look at these objects
and for various reasons and when we look
at a comet or an asteroid maybe in the
night sky with the telescope then they
can glow green and because of the oxygen
that's in them but actually sometimes if
you see a meteor coming through so
basically if you get a little bit of an
asteroid break off in the space and then
head to the earth and you see that as a
fireball in the night sky sometimes they
can glow green and that's for a
different reason so that's something
because we have basically nickel which
is burning up so I mentioned that we had
these
metal asteroids earlier and nickel is is
one of the metals that they have in them
and actually when that burns up in the
atmosphere that blows green so sometimes
you see this kind of green streak with a
meteor quite lucky if you see it I've
never actually seen it so but I know
people talk about it and so that's the
nickel kind of burning up so yes they
definitely have different colors what
was the second part of that question I
forgotten already this is not good no no
your killing life whether the the
ingredients within the tail of a comet
are the right ones to possibly spawn
life yes okay definitely so this has
been quite a recent research finding
actually there we've discovered with
some of the recent missions to comment
so in particular the European Space
Agency sent the Rosetta mission to go
and land on the surface of a comment
back in 2014 now and and they discovered
that was actually the life scene which
is an amino acid and within the comments
so we know there's basically these
complex carbon molecules within them and
so there's every chance that you know
they have the right ingredients for life
and this is why we sort of say well you
know in the past we think earth was
bombarded by comets and asteroids from
space and so it's a plausible way that
we could have bought life and water to
earth because we know that these objects
contain a lot of these ingredients and
we know that asteroids contain hundreds
of amino acids so so these objects in
space they're very old they're very what
we call primitive they're some of the
most the earliest things that formed in
the solar system but they contain all
the ingredients that you need to
basically build a planet and and build
life on that planet so that this is why
I find them such fascinating objects
because they just they have everything
we need and that would mean that life
based on what you just said life could
be vastly more common in the universe
than people might have previously
suspected yes so the problem is there's
a bit of a leap it's from going from
just having the amino acids and the
basic you know carbon compounds and the
molecules to then getting life okay so
that's a massive leap because the
problem is we might have all these
ingredients in space everywhere in fact
they might be in every solar system
we've care to look at but the problem is
it doesn't mean that we've got life
because we need some very special
conditions to let those ingredients
become life like it isn't these are
simple steps
we think they're special conditions
maybe they're common well this is very
true we we have only safer observe life
once and that is on earth but it doesn't
mean that in the hundreds of billions of
galaxies that are out there and all the
stars that there isn't life somewhere
else we just haven't seen it yet no
obviously we don't actually know there's
no other life in our own solar system we
just haven't seen it but we're pretty
sure it doesn't exist on the terrestrial
planets the ones that are near to these
are the rocky ones near to the Sun like
Mercury Venus and Mars maybe they have
life in the past we haven't discovered
that yet and but there is a chance that
there is life on some of these weird
moons like Europa and Enceladus and
things so we're not sure yet but there's
there's a chance it could be because
they've got a lot of the right
ingredients for life they've got liquid
water they've got and that basically
they're energetic bodies they've got
they've got heat that they're losing so
they have all the energy that they could
create life and and help it you know get
along and move along so we just haven't
found it yet we need to go and look we
need some missions to go and and in look
at these places in more detail but
they're challenging environments to send
spacecraft to so that's one of our
problems at the moment as Frankenstein's
new mmm-hmm dr. Frankenstein you can't
just have the raw ingredients you need
energy right and he had like that
lightning bolt going through all that's
right roads on the on the neck yes
that's it Wow well that was well done no
thank you
Natalie also Nicolai didn't know about
nickel no no please you know who knows
about nickel no the gucci brothers for
the fireworks
ah there's all these metals that get
burned in fireworks that give you all
the beautiful colors oh I didn't know
nickel copper what else do they have in
there magnesium I think Natalie yeah
yeah I think that's good yeah so
basically it's a bit like doing that
flame test you might have done that in
chemistry labs at school basically it's
the same principles each element burns
of the different color and I remember
doing this when I was 16 and you kind of
burn the flames and you had some
register what you'd seen with the colors
and sometimes it wasn't very obvious
because you didn't do it very well but
basically this is the principles yeah of
fireworks and everything and what we see
burning
from me Cheers we could tell a lot about
what that asteroid was made of if we can
see it glowing
so yeah it's fascinating all right this
is all news to be here's another one
from Ashley vgt this is off Instagram
mm-hmm I've read that water did not
originate on earth but instead was
introduced by asteroids but wouldn't the
water evaporate away upon entering the
atmosphere ooh burn up burn out coming
in so what so the whole water on earth
thing is is definitely a big open debate
still scientists currently really don't
have a good consensus on where our water
came from so there's the problem is that
if Earth started with all its water from
the beginning so our planet is about 4.5
billion years old it was born out of
this cloud of gas and dust really close
to the Sun and and we think that that
early cloud contained water because are
we going to interstellar space where all
our solar systems are made from and they
sure enough there is water out there
because as ice of course because it's
very cold and now that gets kind of
swept up into the forming star and and
then all the planets are born out of the
cloud of gas and dust that is around
that star so so there's water ice there
that could then be contained within the
planets that we form but the problem is
the very first few million / billion
years of of a planet's infancy it's
incredibly hot so it's basically just
like a volcanic world it really wouldn't
be able to support a lot of water unless
the water was sequestered away very deep
within the planet maybe and and it
didn't evaporate at the surface so we're
not sure whether we could have from the
beginning had our water or whether sure
enough it would have all boiled off
during that process and then we needed
to bring it in later on and we know we
were bombarded by comets and asteroids
about 4 billion years ago we just have
to look at the surface of the Moon for
that actually because you see that that
beautiful cratered surface of the Moon
and actually we were hit by as many
things as the moon was hit by but we
have this thing called plate tectonics
where our surface gets continually
change and updated and resurfaced so
we've lost all their evidence of all
those craters whereas the moon's
preserve them for
so we know that we were hit in the past
and sure enough those comets and
asteroids contained water some of them
did anyway not all of them and and they
could if they didn't if they were large
enough and they didn't evaporate as and
explode completely on re-entry through
the atmosphere and remember our
atmosphere was quite different
back in the day in fact we might have
had much much of a thinner atmosphere
that didn't slow them down as much then
potentially they could have bought a lot
of water with them but for us trying to
figure out where the water came from is
very very tricky because we need to find
out you know what the water looks like
and it's all mixed up now we've got a
mixture of all these different types of
waters so if we want to measure it now
it's very complicated to try and figure
out exactly where it came from and and
all the Comets are different all the
asteroids are different so it's we need
to just go out there and measure more of
these objects so then try and kind of
piece this story together but it's
important so we want to understand why
water's here why are we the only planet
in our solar system with liquid water at
the surface it's a question that we
really want to answer to understand
where life came from as well so that was
a yes that was clear this room Donnie
HUS one one three Oh from Instagram
mm-hmm how much material do asteroids
contain and how much are they worth it's
like a comedian ooh let's sharpen that
and say of the metallic asteroids that
have like metals we care about can you
estimate the value of them and what does
the value mean if they're out there
versus if we brought them back to earth
and now they're just on earth-like value
is just value is a is a flexible thing
in this right exactly it's sort of like
the diamond tissue like there's plenty
of diamonds on earth we combine plenty
of them and actually a lot of them have
been mined but then the diamond market
is controlled because if we released all
those diamonds onto the market in one
guy we'd flood the market and the price
would drop so you know the big diamond
companies don't want that to happen so
they control that market so it's sort of
the same thing with these asteroids and
one asteroid okay so there's a mission a
NASA mission actually going to an
asteroid called 16 psyche and it's made
purely of metal we don't understand a
lot
sestra but it's quite large and actually
the team that are planning to go to this
asteroid have estimated that it's worth
ten thousand quadrillion dollars so and
that's just the iron within that so
basically if they were to mine that
whole asteroid which would be impossible
because it's too larger than we did we
have no way of doing this at the moment
but if we were to be able to figure that
out and we bought all of that metal back
to earth then sure enough we're gonna
flood the market and it wouldn't just
kill the metal market it would kill the
entire economy because we wouldn't know
what to do with all this so so they're
worth a lot but one of the issues is we
don't really know how to currently mind
them we don't know how we would extract
that muscle and we don't necessarily
want to bring it back to the planet to
be quite honest we would like to bring
some back but actually one of the
reasons we want to mine in space is to
be able to further explore space itself
so we could use these materials to
actually you know make things so we
might have a base on the moon where we
actually manufactured materials to and
spacecraft or whatever we needed and
tools to actually go and explore further
into space so there's a lot of
economical questions around mining
asteroids and it's not just the science
of how we do it
it's then looking at you know how it
works and what we're gonna do with the
materials that we get mm-hmm rebuttal no
it's it's funny to just assign a value
to something which if you obtained it
would not have that value yes it's a
weird a weird economic fact it's right
right of this so I never woulda thought
you'd get money out of an asteroid yeah
well plus iron is not uncommon on earth
right so I'm thinking that leave that if
you are gonna bring a metal from an
asteroid to earth you bring a rare metal
that we can use in ways that we can't do
now we can't if you bring all that iron
is there something else you gonna do
with iron that we're not already doing
with iron mm-hmm no that's the thing and
the thing about these asteroids is okay
they contain a lot of iron but and they
contain maybe less than a percent of
precious metals that things like
platinum and gold and these these metals
that we use in technologies a lot in the
modern day and now the thing is they
contain very low percentage of these but
that is still a lot more of these
precious metals than we mine
any one year on our own planet because
the thing is about the precious metals
on earth is that they're distributed
throughout the crust of the earth and
they're not very well concentrated so to
mine them it takes a lot of effort we
have to dig up a lot of land in order to
get those metals rise if we just went to
an asteroid they're a lot easier to
obtain and they're sort of concentrated
in these objects so these are the metals
that are really important because at the
moment we don't have a continued
infinite supply so the kinds of
industrial technologies we're looking
and you know the advanced technologies
who wants to develop a sort of held back
a bit by the fact we don't have this
infinite supply of some of these
precious metals so if we knew that we
could get a lot of them in space and
bring them back then it does open up you
know the engineering world to to new
ideas because they would have enough
supply to be able to do whatever they
wanted I can't you know if my head think
of something that they could do with
them but I'm sure some engineers would
have some great ideas of what they could
do with an infinite amount of platinum
for example a lot of implications of it
I think that's the key point because
it's not that you're just gonna sell the
metal and someone is gonna then make
jewelry out of it or something
there's industry that uses metal yes and
so it enables in it no matter the price
it enables certain industry that
wouldn't otherwise be enabled right
perhaps we shouldn't think of it just as
the metal as a pure thing but the metal
esident as an enabler of other ideas
that engineers would pull out of the box
we got to take a break mark you're still
here oh yeah dr. Natalie Starkey still
there yeah out there outside of London
thanks for piping in we are talking
about asteroids and comets on this
cosmic queries edition of Startalk we'll
see in a moment speaking of space rocks
did you know that Japan has recently
created the first spacecraft to take
subsurface samples of an asteroid
curiosity streams breakthrough videos on
Hayabusa 2 are incredibly fascinating
they'll take you through the launch and
everything it took to make it happen I
couldn't believe that they set off a
freaking explosion to make a hole in the
asteroid wait where have I seen that
before
does anybody have Bruce Willis's number
I think he's being ripped off the
suspense of the probe landing was
killing me while the mission is still
going you can learn more about it by
watching breakthrough on curiosity
stream subscribe now
it's just $2.99 per month and for
Startalk fans the first 31 days are
completely free if you sign up at
curiosity stream dot-com slash Startalk
and use the promo code Startalk
you'll get unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries and nonfiction
series with curiosity stream sign up now
start off we're back cosmic queries
Edition mark Normand oh yeah first-timer
oh yeah I love it here watching dr.
Natalie Starkey you still there with us
expert on comets and asteroids and
that's our topic for the day yeah I
might know a little bit and she knows a
lot oh yeah that's why we brought her on
for this for this episode and to mark my
pet subject you've got questions on this
I got a million we covered that nickel
in the iron if you got a question - you
can do it okay I just wonder if he's
feeling it if you own it if asteroids
contain diamonds and we mined them and
we got the diamonds and diamond prices
went way down on earth would women still
want them that's yeah I mean the thing
is they do contain diamonds and diamonds
we have on earth so they're actually
sort of like interstellar diamonds
they're older then even better our solar
system so they but they're tiny this is
the problem size Queen's fine so you
probably wouldn't you'd need a
microscope to actually see it on your
ring finger but you know you can tell
everyone how special it was a mere you
can't see it but it's interstellar yeah
all right here we are I've read this is
from IO I did that one already this is
from Kimberly dot IO on Instagram
underscore Kimberly IO how often is an
asteroid come across our solar system we
actually had and well we don't really
know if it's an asteroid or a comet but
there was an object recently called a mu
a mu ER and which is a Hawaiian word for
basically kind of like foreign traveler
or something and and it's this object
that appeared and it was traveling very
fast or our solar system
and some astronomers in in Hawaii saw it
and found it first and that's why it got
a Hawaiian name and it was traveling so
fast that they figured out you couldn't
have come you couldn't have originated
within our solar system so they actually
decided that it must have come from
another star system somewhere they have
no idea where exactly they're still
trying to figure that out
and but basically it didn't it was going
so fast it didn't get captured you know
with to our Suns so it just kind of
scooted by and so it didn't enter into
orbit into our solar system and this
object has probably been traveling for
you know potentially billions of years
across interstellar space we don't know
if we're the only solar system it's
traveled through but it's going on this
massive long journey now of course this
object could have actually collided with
the planet and we wouldn't have seen it
coming because it was going so quickly
and it was relatively small it was very
dark and it's a really really hard to
spot but the thing we realize now is
that we've spotted it because our
technology has got so much better at
trying to spot things in the night sky
it's actually probably happened before
probably we've had these visitors from
other parts of you know the galaxy many
times before but we've just not seen
them and sure enough our own comets and
asteroids could be out there visiting
other star systems and it's just
something that happens during the
process of forming a star and the
planets around it that is a little bit
chaotic and so comets and asteroids are
essentially the bits and pieces leftover
that didn't become a planet and
sometimes because they're small they can
get a ejected out of the solar system or
they get thrown into the Sun and they
end in a fiery death but some of them
get thrown out and and they just you
know end up leaving the Sun's gravity
and they go off into space and then
there's nothing stopping them they're
gonna keep going so so yeah it's really
cool that we've got these objects if we
can start to identify more of them in
the future and actually look for them
then we might got some launch mission to
go and maybe sample one one day which
would be amazing cuz we'll find out
about the chemistry of another star
system which is something that I would
be really interested in and but yeah at
the moment we've only seen one and it's
kind of gone now it's exiting the solar
system and it's going on its merry way
into the abyss Wow
it's very way into the abyss beautiful
poetic I looked up how more and more I
think it means scout
first Scouts journey person onto a new
lamp into a new place let's go yeah it
is quick question may not be answerable
from Paul Pimenta on Facebook can we
track where asteroids came from
specifically where they originated mm
yeah yeah definitely
um so actually I mean it's even better
than that sometimes we get a meteorite
that ends up on the on the planet so
this is just a rock from space that will
usually come from NASA right or it can
come from another planet if we've seen
that coming through the night sky and
coming burning up through the atmosphere
and then there's lots of basically
camera networks out there now and one of
them is in the deep Australian outback
and they just basically have cameras set
on the night sky to register these
objects as they're coming in and what
they're trying to do is figure out an
exact trajectory for them so that they
can basically backtrack that with some
amazing math and and actually figure out
where that object originated and try and
track it back to the asteroid belt
itself and we can sort of check our
calculations in a certain way by
analyzing the chemistry of those rocks
so we can go and pick up that rock
because basically they know where it's
landed because they've got that
trajectory coming in on the cameras they
can go and pick that rock analyze it in
the lab and compare it to what we know
about the objects and the asteroids that
already and from telescopes studies or
from having analyzed them before and
actually we've started to be able to
figure out like different families of
objects so we can say oh it's from this
type of asteroid and and we know that
they're in this part of the asteroid
belt maybe in the middle part or the
outer part of the belt so yes it's
actually possible it's very complicated
work but it and with making much more
progress with it in probably the last
decade or so and but yes we can
definitely start to figure out and we
also know if it came from another planet
that's much easier to work out actually
it came from another planet than than
any old particular asteroid because
there's kind of billions of them out
there so that's it is tricky
billions of asteroids but many fewer
planets yeah there aren't there aren't
too many planets and kilometer in the
asteroid belt so there's an awful lot of
them and there's millions more smaller
ones so
there are a lot of objects out there but
a lot of them as I said they're in these
these groups they're in families they
are all different they all there are
groups that share similarities and where
they were made and what they contain
it's like a 23andme but for an actual it
is I'm Jewish all right how large does
from Rene Douglas patreon listen up how
large does a captured asteroid need to
be in order to be called a moon and can
a comet also be captured mm-hmm yes so
the first part I mean in fact the it
depends what you cast as a moon ray
because some of the asteroids themselves
have moons around them and we've
actually started to scar I think we've
found about 200 moons around asteroids
now so these are just small objects
orbiting and basically attached to that
asteroid in some way that they're
associated with it and now the thing
about the asteroids themselves is that
even the largest asteroid we know of
which is Sarah's is only about a quarter
the size of our Moon so even the biggest
one and even if you pack them all
together so you take all the asteroids
in the asteroid belt and put them all
together in one blob and they would only
be about four percent of the mass of the
moon so there's a lot of them out there
but they're just not very big so if you
wanted to capture an asteroid well you
wouldn't be capturing one of the largest
ones and because this sort of like you
know a thousand well hundreds of
kilometers in diameter so it is too
large to capture when NASA have actually
done some studies looking at potentially
capturing an asteroid with sort of a bag
or something it sounds kind of crazy but
that's literally what they're sort of
planning or a scoop and and and they're
looking at something around 40 meters
and so it's not going to be particularly
massive and it's not going to pose a
problem to earth if it goes very wrong
although that would still be an issue if
that collided with the planet so see ya
in terms of capturing them you wouldn't
capture something really massive because
you I mean if it went wrong you'd be
really in trouble and if that collided
with earth wow this is alright how do we
know that more of them I mean I don't
know any
I'm on Molly right now but why don't we
get hit by more asteroids and realize it
and feel it well we do get hit ok their
plows through now a correct me if I'm
wrong several hundred tons of meteor
dust a day descend on earth just by
plowing through interplanetary space and
does it make a dent no most of it just
just settles as dust because it lost all
its energy coming through the atmosphere
it was big enough to hold a relationship
an inverse relationship so the bigger
the asteroid that's heading for the
planet or it's going to come through the
atmosphere the less frequently it hits
so the really small pieces of just
they're literally raining down all the
time and they're called micro meteorites
or basically Stardust and and then if
you go to the larger objects like the
ones that killed off the dinosaurs for
example then they don't hit very
frequently you know every 10,000 maybe 1
million years or more and probably more
in fact for once that size we had an
event in Russia back in 2013 it was
called Chelyabinsk and it was about a 20
meter asteroid and so it's fairly large
I guess kind of like a double-decker bus
and that didn't actually kill anybody
but it did cause quite a lot of damage
in the region and it had this big sonic
boom as it came through the atmosphere
and actually it blew windows and
everything in the inch elements town and
so and we didn't know that was coming
because it was actually quite small we
didn't we didn't see it we hadn't
spotted it before it arrives so you know
yes they happen and obviously if that
I'd hit central London I'm pretty close
to central London that's about 60 miles
across maybe if you take Greater London
into account and actually that would be
quite an issue if that had landed in the
centre of London so it just it's sort of
lucky that most of the planet is sort of
empty and a lot of these asteroids tend
to land in the ocean so me don't see
them and they don't cause us any harm
but yeah they do hit all the time and
they're just larger ones not as often
well have you gonna hit somewhere I
think Russia's the place come on is that
a political statement of work or jus
Geographic State Wow I don't know
anything about collusion it's the
country with the largest landmass
good that's what I was saying so it's
gonna get more asteroids than any more
comet collision I know
to say that's that's good but that's
what they get for conquering you conquer
you gotta realize that you gonna hit
more asteroids there you go it's alright
here we go
natalie is from Frank Cain patreon
member out of Orlando Florida is there a
really clear distinction between comets
and asteroids I mean comics generally
have some rock in them and asteroids
have a lot of frozen gas in them right
where do we draw the line oh yeah other
way around so the asteroids are kind of
the rocky hard metallic ones classically
and then the comments are sort of the
icy dusty dusty snowballs or whatever
you want to call them and but yeah this
this sort of works and it is a pretty
like old distinction that we always fall
back on and but it's a very classical
view of these objects and actually what
we're finding as we go and look at more
and more of them is that we've got a lot
of asteroids that can contain quite a
lot of water ice and other ices like
methane and things and we have some
comments that are completely dry because
for example if they've been around the
Sun a lot of times and and they've been
basically having their volatile ices
burnt off all the time then and they're
going to be dry and they sort of looked
there for like an asteroids so there's a
lot of there's almost like a continuum
we think potentially as a continuum of
compositions we've got some things that
definitely look like this classical
asteroid some things that definitely
like a comment that's very icy and then
a lot of material in between and at the
moment we're still trying to piece
together that story of basically where
these objects formed and therefore what
they're then made of today and they've
also been affected by what they've gone
through in that 4.6 billion year history
since they formed so yeah basically we
have that distinction but it doesn't
always work but we have yet to see a
Metallica Comet true but they do yeah
but yeah that's very true we haven't I
mean if you had a purely metal object
out there then it's definitely an
asteroid in fact you know this 16 psyche
asteroid that they want to go and look
at they think could be the center of a
planet and that was kind of blown to
pieces at some point in the past and
when a lot it might maybe collided with
another asteroid so it had basically in
the earth we've got this metallic core
and that's what happens to these the
large objects in the solar system they
differentiate so they're a big ball of
magma and then the heavy material in
that magma the metal falls to the middle
of the planet and the lighter stuff is
on the outside so if they experience an
impact all of this what we call the
crust and the mantle which is the
lightest stuff on the planet it gets
kind of blown off the surface and you
get left with this solid core which is
very hard to break up so that's what we
think that's one theory of what this
asteroid could be so we can study it to
actually look at the core of a planet
which is incredibly hard to do because
we can't drill to the core of a planet
so these objects are really valuable
scientifically for that reason Wow and
how come could we film them and watch
them hit each other I feel like there'd
be a great pay-per-view be cool very
cool pay-per-view you could bet on them
like with the mob so we gotta take a
break we'll be back for our third of
three seconds of cosmic queries
asteroids and comets edition with dr.
Nathalie Starkey when we return this
episode of Star talk is brought to you
by curiosity stream star talk we're back
cosmic queries asteroids and comets
edition with our friend and colleague
Natalie Starkey Natalie Sohn and in from
London outside of London yes you in the
stateside you were here for three years
and then you just left us I know I know
I miss California as well but um it's
really far from home so it's quite nice
to be back in the rain said no one ever
shishi brexit it yes sorry so mark yo
I'm my co-host for today yeah what do
you have for us here we go go voidwalker
92 off Instagram
are there any asteroids with their own
natural satellites currently known if so
how common or uncommon is this and how
does the dynamic effect
tref tracking and understanding
trajectory of the asteroid oh nice yeah
that makes it a little bit of n really
really know that quite a lot of
asteroids have moons so natural
satellites around them and it's probably
other bits of a material of that same
asteroid but we're not sure because we
haven't
them in detail one of the problems is
that we can't actually see them very
easily because the asteroids themselves
are small and therefore their moons
around them are even smaller so we found
about I think is over 200 moons around
asteroids now so we definitely know
they're there we want to study them more
detail because it will tell us more
about that object itself and how that
object formed do you think those
asteroid do you think those moons
dislodged from the asteroid itself to
become a means one option or it could be
that they captured them like so some of
the moons that we see around planets are
either captured moons so they're formed
somewhere else in the solar system to
that planet and then basically that
planet was large and so it's gravity
attracted other objects to it and our
own moon for example didn't form in that
way it formed from the earth itself
during a massive collision about
four-and-a-half billion years ago and
and it basically threw off a bit of our
own planet and then it coalesced into a
moon and it was then you know trapped
with the earth so there's different ways
to form them but we need to study more
of them to figure out exactly how they
formed all right that's question well
said well said Richard Stenhouse from
Facebook
hi guys love the show I've been
listening on Spotify since September
2018 whilst I'm at work and I'm as far
back as season two can't get enough it's
like a regular Natalie get to it is
there a point between stars where comets
or asteroids are under no influence of
gravity at all and if they somehow lost
momentum would they hang in that space
till the end of time from North Wales UK
I love it love the questions a great
question oh my goodness cuz I actually
only found out recently myself that some
of the comets like that are in our all
cloud which is that the cloud of
material that's outside of our but it
kind of surrounds our solar system so
everything in our solar system is on a
plane it's on a disk all the planets and
all the comments and all the asteroids
and then we've got this all cloud around
us which is all these icy objects of
which we actually have never really seen
any of them because they're so far away
and some of them on the edge of that all
cloud are so far away that they're
almost not gravitationally bound to our
own
and they're almost closer to the next
star system so so sure enough I don't
know what happens at that point I mean I
guess maybe some really clever
astrophysicists maybe figure out what is
happening to these objects out there but
but yeah they could easily be perturbed
we would say they might be pushed around
by the gravity of another star system
and then and then either thrown out of
our solar system completely or pushed in
so that they actually come in and visit
visit the Sun and the inner solar system
but but that's a great question yeah
they're susceptible but we the Sun the
planets and everything that the family
we're all orbiting the center of the
galaxy nah
among other stars so even if you have a
precariously positioned comet at the
edge of this Oort cloud and it doesn't
have a gravitational Allegiance
eventually it will because we're moving
past other stars
somebody's gonna snatch it yes and or
perturb it and have it descend back down
into our star so so yeah the things are
always in motion and if you're without
Allegiance that wouldn't be for long
mm-hmm
I'm so jealous and just to be clear or
it is named for a guy named yon court
who is a Dutch astronomer of mid-century
no I'm serious Ron who first proposed
the existence of this reservoir of
comets was he still not really proven as
such but because we've not really seen
it so it's just so far away we'll never
get there and you know even if there's a
spaceship out there now like Voyager
they are not gonna get there for tens of
thousands of years say yeah jeez it's a
tricky one
could we get a GoPro on one I know if
you think why not Plus this was mid 20th
century you asked if he was persecuted
for suggesting this oh sorry relatively
modern time right 1950s right we're not
persecuting they were very religious
then right right you know what a mess
with it all right
here we go Brett LaRue also patreon if
we were to mine a significant amount of
a comet would this change its orbit and
if so how could we be sure this would
not set into motion future collisions
would result in a major earth impact hmm
oh let me generalize that question as we
start poking around with astral landing
on them mining them what risk does that
pose to taking what was previously a
safe orbit and turning it into an earth
crossing orbit that could then kill us
yeah it's a huge risk it is a huge risk
but this is why and the people that are
looking at doing it are probably looking
at focusing on the smaller asteroids all
comments if they want to look at
comments but it's generally asteroids
we're talking about at the moment and
because then if they were to dislodge it
onto an orbit that was then a hazardous
one for our planet then it hopefully
would burn up in the atmosphere and not
cause us any issues but in terms of
mining them we probably wouldn't just go
to them in mind then we'd want to drag
them somewhere to what we would consider
a safe orbit and so this might be near
the moon where basically you can just
kind of dump the stuff and it just sort
of sits there it's this gravitational
sweet spot where and the thing basically
if there's small enough object it's not
going to go anywhere and then what you
could do is have a base on the moon and
go back and forth to that object and
mine it gradually so you'd basically
just want to get it somewhere safe first
because sure enough if you start mining
it you are gonna you're probably gonna
change this orbit in some way and then
it's hard to predict how it's gonna spin
and where it's going to end up in the
future good question Wow all right
coming fascinating stuff here I wish I
cared when the asteroids headed your way
you'll care that's true become the most
important people in the world the day
that happens yeah I've seen the Bruce
Willis movie generally jealous because
you guys care so much that you it makes
you learn I'm gonna die alone and an
idiot because I don't care about
anything I'm dead inside
all right Doug Bartlett on Facebook I
know we have found organic material in
tardigrades on asteroids my question is
are these tardigrades thriving
quote-unquote on these asteroids or in a
state of hibernation if alive could it
be possible that two asteroids collide
or contact and crossbreed organisms
organisms
okay so I'm entirely convinced we have
found tardigrades on asteroids nailed
you that's true because
living and we haven't found anything
living
so these toiling rates are like these
crazy organisms that can basically
survive anything they're insane and they
can extreme pressures and temperatures
and they can also just go into
hibernation for I think like millions of
years and they can just basically
survive anything and then come back to
life again
I literally this is the very edge of my
knowledge about these things this is a
very much astrobiology which is not what
I do but they haven't been found on
asteroids but I think the theory they're
talking about is panspermia where we're
basically looking at transporting
biological material around the solar
system and from one object object to
another and and that's one of the
theories of how life got to earth in
fact it's not that we'll accept it in I
don't know I don't if it's fair to say
that but I mean I I don't believe it
personally I don't think that's how I've
got to earth and but you know there is a
chance that the basic building blocks
for life the the more basic carbon
molecules came you know from comets and
asteroids and were delivered to earth in
that way but the actual organisms
themselves weren't as far as I'm
concerned anyway well but you just said
that the tardigrade can survive anything
so it could survive a trip through space
as a stowaway yeah in the nooks and
crannies on a rock that got catapulted
from one planet to another so you've
said that earlier in this program Wow I
did I did just say that and now you're
saying that you're not buying it oh yeah
calling you out so I think the issue is
we need you know we like some scientific
proof so we need to do those experiments
we need to take close bugs into space
and I'm you know I'm sure actually on
the outside of the International Space
Station they've taken organisms and
they're basically seeing how they react
to that radiation environment because
it's not only temperature and pressures
obviously we don't like radiation our
biological cells can't deal with it we
get cancer and we die very quickly in
fact you know the astronauts are going
to space there are much higher risk of
radiation poisoning than you would be on
the planet so this is one of the
problems that biological material has in
space so we need to do those experiments
we need to take those bugs out into deep
space and see if they survive and then
see if we can grow things out there as
well and so until we do that I'm I'm
sure that things can survive in deep
space with no sunlight for kind of
billions of years that we that we'd
require but you know I may be totally
wrong that's a good way to end every
statement you make I prefer the term
special needs grades okay tardigrades
yeah I see what you did there well done
both this is quite a speed date so so
Natalie we're running out of time do you
have any sort of reflections simple
reflections you'd like the viewer
listener to take with them as a lesson
for this program yeah I think I think
you know someone like me you probably
like wondering why I'm so interested in
these objects and I think it's just
because I'm inherently interested in
where we came from you know we're not on
this planet for very long most of us a
hundred years if we're lucky and and in
that time I think well let's give a
purpose to our life I'd love to figure
out why we're here how we got here and
and what we're leaving to our future
descendants and if basically we may have
only got here because of comets and
asteroids and actually in the future we
may die off because of comets and
asteroids they could collide with us and
you know devastate all of humanity so
all I want to understand these objects
for many reasons because of how we got
here but also to protect us in the
future and we need to understand what
these things are made of and what their
orbits are and understanding so much
details that we can actually protect the
planet I think it's important I think
everyone should be concerned about it
but not worried I don't think we need to
be worried it's tomorrow we're all gonna
die in an asteroid impact although it
could happen but I think it's something
we need to be concerned with for this
for the future so no we're not leaving a
ruined planet to in may be it will be
ruined in other ways but we're not gonna
leave it ruins with an asteroid impact
in the future and we can hopefully do
something about it and yeah asteroid
before hits I'd like to think I just
picking up on your point Natalie it is
in truth it's an intriguing and
underappreciated fact that asteroids and
comets may have been the bringers of
life if not the ingredients of life but
perhaps even life itself and yet they
can also serve as harbingers of doom for
the very life that it brought well
Yoda planet and that is a cosmic
perspective you've been listening to
possibly even watching this episode of
star talk cosmic queries asteroids and
comets edition
I want to thank Natalie Starkey friend
and colleague who went back across the
pond good luck in your your new science
teaching exploits at the Open University
in the UK and it's always great to have
you and how do how will people find more
of you out there and I am Starkey
Stardust on Twitter and Instagram I need
to not be struggles is my name others
say Starkey Stardust great band from the
60s and you also one of our star talk
all-stars
I am yeah so I have other shows that you
can go and listen to I've had about four
now so I've got some of water in the
solar system and a lot of our story
stuff I'd lick turns the Mars insight
mission which is actually on Mars at the
moment so there's a few things you can
go and check out nice very good and
we'll put a link to those shows in the
description excellent excellent
and Mark you're you get around I get
around I'm on the road every weekend
doing the road again my comedy stylings
in a comedy club near you and go to mark
Normand comedy dot-com and I love your
dates insightful and clever and funny I
love yours
what more can we ask for what the world
needs today your big inspiration your
traffic light tweet a joke that's a bit
oh my god
yeah I'm obsessed with jokes and that's
a great joke oh you know I tried joking
but it's you know they don't always land
but you know I'm coming from I love it I
love coming all right that's boom star
talk I've been your host Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist and
as always I bid you to keep looking up
thanks to curiosity stream for
supporting this episode of star talk if
you enjoyed this episode about space
rocks
you'll love curiosity streams
breakthrough series about japan's
Hayabusa 2 spacecraft
it'll bring a subsurface sample of an
asteroid back to earth by the end of
next year
well that's if everything goes right I
watched direct from an asteroid and
curiosity streams breakthrough series
and
it really broke down what it takes to
get to an asteroid blow up part of it
and grab a sample and get back to earth
fascinating stuff you can watch it for
just $2.99 per month and if you go to
curiosity stream comm slash star talk
and use code star talk your first 31
days are free go there right now with
over 2400 documentary features and
series to enjoy it's a great deal
you